[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne gellineck guten Abend der
Krieg im Nahen Osten ist auch ein
Psychokrieg alle Mitglieder der
Terrororganisation Hamas sein to sagte
Israels Premierminister Netanyahu heute
markig über der Erde unter der Erde in
Gaza und außerhalb von Gaza Hamas
konterte auf grausame Weise rund 50
Geiseln sein bei den israelischen
Luftschlägen auf den Gazastreifen ums
Leben gekommen ob das stimmt weiß
niemand gleichzeitig soll eine
Delegation der Terrororganisation in
Moskau eingetroffen sein man Rede über
die Freilassung von Geiseln verkündet
die russische Regierung nicht oh ohne
Stolz unterdessen ging der Krieg am
Boden und in der Luft weiter Tim Kröger
berichtet von oben wird das Ausmaß
sichtbar Satellitenaufnahmen sollen die
Zerstörung in Gaza seit dem Beginn der
israelischen Luftangriffe nach dem Hamas
Massaker am 7 Oktober zeigen und die
Kämpfe gehen unvermindert weiter in der
Nacht sollen israelische Bodentruppen
mit Panzern in den Gasastreifen
eingerückt sein und hamasziele
angegriffen haben auch zur Stunde
operieren offenbar israelische Einheiten
in
Gaza das ist ein tödlicher genauer und
ein kraftvoller
Angriff er kommt aus der Luft am Boden
und über das
Meer er trifft die Bunker die Tunnel die
Schächte er trifft die Stellungen die
Kommunikation er trifft die
Terroristen aber auch die
Zivilbevölkerung im Gaza ist betroffen
nach Angaben der Hamas seien auch 50 der
Geiseln unter den Opfern eine
Bestätigung dafür gibt es nicht der
katarische Nachrichtensender aljasira
berichtet dass bei Angriffen gestern
Familienangehörige seines Gaza
korespondenten alachu verletzt und
getötet
wurden das ist wirklich eine große
Katastrophe vor allem weil eine so große
Zahl an Frauen und Kindern betroff war
als das Haus getroffen
wurde weiterhin bemühen sich
Hilfsorganisationen dringend benötigte
Hilfsgüter in den Gasastreifen zu
bringen es gibt einen ernsthaften Mangel
an Lebensmitteln an Treibstoff und
Medikamenten das wissen wir durch unsere
Arbeit in den Notunterkünften
in Tel Aviv fordern am Nachmittag
Angehörige wie jeden Tag die schnelle
Rückkehr der von der Hammers
verschleppten
Geiseln auf einmal Luftalarm die meisten
der Raketen aus Gaza werden vom
Luftabwehrsystem abgefangen in der Stadt
petara aber ist zuvor bereits ein
Geschoss in ein Haus eingeschlagen zwei
Menschen werden verletzt es ist der 20
Kriegstag
der Terrorangriff der Hamas und seine
Folgen haben den herbstgipfel der
europäischen Staats und Regierungschefs
und Chefinnen nahezu komplett gekarpert
und schonungslos eins der großen
Probleme der EU offenelegt sie ist nur
stark wenn sie mit einer Stimme spricht
beim Thema Nahost ging das schon immer
schief im aktuellen Fall herrscht
heilloses Durcheinander erst wollte die
EU-Kommission die Hilfen für die
Palästinenser streichen dann
verdreifachte sie die Hilfen es gibt
Gerangel wer eigentlich die Außenpolitik
macht und Streit um die Frage ob die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten von Israel einen
Waffenstillstand fordern sollten oder
mehrere kurze waffenpausen über die
europäische wortgymnastik berichtet
Florian
Neuhann es kommt heute in Brüssel auf
jeden Satz an auf jedes einzelne Wort
und zugleich aufs große Ganze die Welt
will wissen was sagt Europa zum Krieg im
Nahen Osten hat es eine
Stimme wir werden in einer Welt von bald
10 Milliarden Einwohnern nur dann
bedeutend sein wenn wir unsere 400
irgendwann 500 Millionen zusammenun und
das mit einer Stimme tun Europa ringt um
die richtige Forderung vdergründig um
den passenden Begriff humanitärer Zugang
oder Korridor Zeitfenster oder Pause
Pausen oder
waffentillstand hinter dem Streit steckt
grundsät
auf der einen Seite Regierungschefs die
Israel zwar pflichtbewusst die
Solidarität erklären und sich dann für
die andere palästinensische Seite
einsetzen ich bin nicht besessen davon
welches Wort wir verwenden aber wir
wollen dass das Töten und die Gewalt
aufhört sodass humanitäre Hilfe nach
Gaza kommt wo unschuldige Palästinenser
leiden israel hat das Recht sich und
seine Bevölkerung zu verteidigen aber
kann niemals eine Entschuldigung dafür
sein Gaza zu
blockieren es sind Sätze die andere in
der Runde so nicht sagen würden ein
Drittel der Staats- und Regierungschefs
hat Israel in den letzten zwei Wochen
selbst besucht die israelunterstützer
angeführt vom deutschen Kanzler der dem
Land auch heute sein volles Vertrauen
ausspricht Israel ist ein demokratischer
Staat mit sehr humanitären Prinzipien
die ihn leiten und deshalb kann man
sicher sein
dass die israelische Armee auch bei dem
was sie macht die Regeln beachten wird
die sich aus dem Völkerrecht ergeben da
habe ich keinen Zweifel Europas Spitzen
verhacken sich im Streit um den Nahen
Osten da wird der Krieg im noch näheren
Osten und die Videokonferenz mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten beinah zur
Randnotiz wenn die Eskalation zwischen
Israel und Palästina voranschreitet dann
würde das unsere Aufmerksamkeit
natürlich weiter von der Ukraine
ablenken und das wäre eine weitere gute
Botschaft für den Kremmel aber nicht für
uns eine weitere Krise Europa sortiert
sich neu in der Ukraine Frage blockiert
der Ungar Viktor Orban Europas weitere
Unterstützung in der Israel Frage findet
er sich plötzlich im selben Lager wie
der deutsche
Kanzler wir sind sehr klar für das
israelische Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung
eren Europa ist immer für Überraschungen
gut die größte kommt vor ein paar
Minuten eine Einigung auf eine
gemeinsame Haltung zum Nahen
Osten darüber wollen wir reden mit
unseren Korrespondenten in Brüssel und
in telaviv zuerst nach Brüssel zu Ulf
Röller Ulf offenbar gibt's ja eine
Einigung haben wir gerade gehört worauf
hat man sich geeinigt und was bedeutet
das also 5 Stunden haben die
Regierungschefs gerungen und es war
kurzzeitig nicht mal klar ob es wirklich
eine Schlusserklärung gibt es war nicht
sicher ob es eine Einigung gibt die gibt
es jetzt man hat noch mal sehr deutlich
gemacht dass Israel jedes Recht hat sich
selbst zu verteidigen man hat noch mal
den Terror der Hamas verurteilt und man
hat eben jetzt humanitäre Korridore
gefordert und diese sogenannten kurzen
Feuerpausen damit der leidenden
Bevölkerung Gazastreifen geholfen werden
kann wichtig ist was nicht drin steht
Irland und Spanien vor allem wollten
dass auch ein Waffenstillstand von der
EU gefordert wird da hat vor allem
Deutschland sehr deutlich gesagt nein
das wollen wir nicht weil das würde das
Recht von Israel auf Selbstverteidigung
einschränken also es gibt jetzt diese
Einigung und die EU hofft dass sie mit
dieser Einigung als Partner im Nahen
Osten wirklich ernst genommen wird und
auch ein Partner bleibt und man hofft
natürlich dass diese Einigung auch ein
bisschen hält danke Ulf und damit gehen
wir weiter zu Michael
nach Tel Michael eine Reihe von
europäischen Regierungschefs hat sich ja
heute deutlich Israel kritisch geäußert
jetzt also die Einigung auf kurze
Feuerpausen wie kommt das an wird Israel
sich daran
halten also es gibt hier noch keine
offiziellen Kommentierungen aber ich
kann mir vorstellen dass das
hier in fast allen politischen Lagern
eher mit müder Enttäuschung quittiert
wird nachdem die vielen Staats und
Regierungschefs die noch vor wenigen
Tagen hier sich die Klinke in die Hand
gegeben haben um das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht von Israel zu
bestätigen nun wieder ganz
widersprüchliche Signale aussenden man
muss wissen dass der militärische Druck
die Bombardements und natürlich auch das
Zulassen humanitärer Hilfe das einzige
Druckmittel ist was Israel hat um auf
die Befreiung der Geisel hinzuwirken und
natürlich darf Israel nicht einfach die
Zivilbevölkerung von Gaza in Mithaftung
nehmen aber die Hamas nimmt die bevölk
von Gasa auch in Mithaftung und
vielleicht dürfte der eine oder andere
hier ein ähnliches Signal auch an die
Hamas erwartet haben vielleicht den
Geiseln freizugeben um so auch weitere
humanitäre Hilfe weitere humanitäre zu
ermöglichen ich würde sagen auch dieser
Gipfel wird wieder mal hier als die
typische europäische Wankelmütigkeit
verbucht werden und letztendlich
abgehakt werden danke ihnen beiden nach
Israel und in die europäische Hauptstadt
Michael bwerunge und und ulfräuer waren
das vielen
Dank während Europa also noch um eine
einheitliche Position in Sachen Israel
gerungen hat sehen viele muslimische
Länder ihr Weltbild über den Westen
bereits bestätigt der türkische
Präsident Rchb tayb Erdogan Beklagte am
Nachmittag die Gleichgültigkeit Europas
gegenüber dem Leid von Muslimen der
Westen beachte die Gewalt im
Gazastreifen nicht weil das vergossene
Blut muslimisches Blut sei sagt der
Erdogan der Vorwurf von westlicher
Doppelmoral kommt auch aus der
arabischen Welt hier wird der brutaleer
Anschlag der Hamas nur als einer von
vielen in einem langen Konflikt zwischen
Israel und den Palästinensern gesehen
goline ATI
berichtet am Grenzübergang von Raffa
vergangene Woche hier trifft eine
ägyptische Journalistin auf die
Korrespondentin des US-amerikanischen
sendes
CNN
wir stehen bei den Palästinensern bei
den Arabern wo sind unsere Stimmen die
müssen doch auch bei euch gehört werden
wir schauen eure Fernsehsender aber
statt bei euch Trauer um unsere Toten
palästinensischen Kinder zu sehen sehen
wir wie ihr immer weiter die Araber
entmchlicht Palästina die nie Gehalte
arabische Wunde Proteste in Ciro in
Bagdad Proteste selbst beim US
Verbündeten
bahreinelten
erhoben arabische Straßen solch lauter
Anklage gegen die USA und
Europa der Westen hat ein enormes
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem in der
arabischen Welt ihr verlangt vom
globalen Süden Russland zu verurteilen
weil es Land besetzt aber ihr verurteilt
nicht Israel für seine Besetzung von
palästinensischem Land eure
Doppelstandards sind für jeden
offensichtlich im Gespräch mit uns
berichtet der Diplomat von einem
geopolitischen Scherbenhaufen es
Schmerze ihn zu sehen wie sich nun
selbst jene Kollegen vom Westen abwenden
würden die stets zugewandt gewesen
sein der Westen behandle arabisches Leid
anders lautet der Vorwurf
palästinensisches Leid sei einfach nur
Teil des Krieges während israelisches
Leid berühre und
bewege Kritik Nummer 2 der Westen vor
allem Deutschland akzeptiere Israels
völkerrechtsverstöße sicher wenn wir
über Russland oder China reden dann
erwartet niemand dass sie sich an
internationales Recht halten aber die
Menschen hier erwarten immer noch dass
der Westen sich an diese Standards und
Ideale Heldt das Völkerrecht ist nicht
optional für den Terror der Hamas gebe
es keine Rechtfertigung sagt Ägyptens
Menschenrechtler h und setzt den Terror
mit Israels bombarderung von Gaza
gleich vor allem die deutsche Regierung
ist Teil dieses moralischen Versagens
des Westens in ihrer bedingungslosen
Unterstützung der Besatzungsmacht Israel
verhindert Deutschland dass
Menschenleben gerettet werden
können ein schwerer Vorwurf den viele
hier
Teilen der bestialische Terror der Hamas
in Israel ist der für viele Symbol und
Fortsetzung antisemitischer
Gewalt in der arabischen Welt hingegen
ist der Terror vor allem eine Folge der
Diskriminierung der
Palästinenser doch so sehr sich
arabische Stimmen über fehlen Empathie
für Palästinenser beklagen im arabischen
Fernsehen ist israelisches Leid
vollständig
ausgeblendet und hier geht's weiter mit
den Nachrichten von gundola Gause und
die beginnen mit einer
kehtwende die Slowakei hat wie
angekündigt ihre militärhilf für die
Ukraine gestoppt der neue slowakische
Ministerpräsident fizzo erklärte auch
die EU solle sich von einem
Waffenlieferanten zu einem
Friedensstifter wandeln ihre humanitäre
Hilfe werde die Slowakei
fortsetzen in der Ukraine verstärkt die
russische Armee ihre Angriffe auf afdiv
Janka in der Region Donetzk
verschiedenen Quellen zufolge muss das
ukrainische Militär dort Rückschläge
hinnehmen die Kleinstadt ist nach
monatelangen Kämpfen fast völlig
zerstört wieder erschüttert ein Amoklauf
die USA im Bundesstaat Main hat ein Mann
um sich geschossen und ist seitdem auf
der Flucht 18 Menschen wurden getötet
und 13 verletzt als der 40jährige in
einem Restaurant und in einer bowlingbar
mit einem Sturmgewehr das Feuer
eröffnete die Bevölkerung in der Gegend
wurde aufgerufen in ihren Häusern zu
bleiben der Mann sei bewaffnet und
gefährlich zu möglichen Motiven ist
bislang nichts
bekannt an der Westküste Mexikos sind
bei einem Hurrican mindestens 27
Menschen ums Leben gekommen vier werden
noch vermisst vor allem in dem Badeort
akapulko richtete der als extrem
gefährlich eingestufte Hurrican Otis
massive Schäden an die Autobahn nach
Mexiko Stadt wurde nach Erdrutschen
gesperrt zeitweise waren hunderttausende
Haushalte ohne Strom auch Internet und
frü Warnsysteme brachen
zusammen mit einer bundesweiten Razia
ist die Polizei gegen die rechtsextreme
Musikszene vorgegangen durchsucht wurden
zahlreiche Gebäude in sechs
Bundesländern sowie auf Mallorca wegen
des Verdachts der Produktion und des
Vertriebs von menschenverachtenden und
gewaltverherrlichenden Texten der
mutmaßliche Rädelsführer wurde in
Niedersachsen verhaftet 10ta000ende CDs
und Datenträger
beschlagnahmt in Bayern haben CSU und
Freie Wähler die Neuauflage ihrer
Koalition besiegelt der CSU Vorsitzende
Söder erklärte nach der
Vertragsunterzeichnung die Debatte mit
den Freien Wählern und ihrem
Vorsitzenden eiwanger um dessen
flugblatffäre sei beendet die Freien
Wähler bekommen mit dem digitalressort
ein viertes Ministerium im neuen
Landestag im neuen im neuen Landtag
haben sie mit 37 sitzen Zeh mehr als
zuvor die CSU hat unverändert
85 die Gewerkschaft werdi setzte am
Morgen schon mal den Ton man sei das
Gejammere der Arbeitgeber wirklich leid
nie sei Geld da für die Beschäftigten
aber für allen anderen Quatsch so die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende von werdi
wörtlich ab heute also
Tarifverhandlungen für die Beschäftigten
im öffentlichen Dienst der Bundesländer
verhandelt wird für Ärztinnen Pfleger
justizbeamt
Lehrerinnen und kitaerzieher insgesamt
1,2 Millionen Menschen eigentlich sogar
3 Millionen weil die Beamten den
Tarifabschluss fast immer übernehmen die
Forderung
10,5% mehr Einkommen bitter nötig sagen
die Gewerkschaften denn der Abstand
zwischen denen die Vollzeit arbeiten und
denen die Sozialleistungen beziehen wird
immer geringer Alexander röttig mit
einem
Fallbeispiel Nachtschicht Frühdienst
Überstunden für Achim Hirz vom Bund der
strafvzugsbediensteten Alltag eine
zellenkontrolle ohne Anwesenheit des
inhaftierten ist problemlos doch immer
wieder gibt's auch handfesten Ärger mit
Häftlingen wir haben immer mehr
psychisch auffällige Gefangene wo wir
mit umgehen müssen die uns teilweise
nicht verstehen wo wir dann ja
Schwierigkeiten haben denen zu erklären
was wir wollen und die haben halt ihre
Art und Weise das uns darzulegen was sie
wollen das führt zu Bedrohung
Beleidigung ab und zu gibt es auch
Übergriff für all das bekommt er nach 25
Dienstjahren 3600 € netto zu wenig meint
er als arbeitsloser Vater von zwei
Kindern bekäme er je nach Wohnungsgröße
bis zu 3000 € an Unterstützung vom Staat
Miete Bürgergeld andere Zuschüsse
rechnet er vor 600 € Unterschied der
Abstand Stimme nicht wir arbeiten 41
Stunden die Woche wir arbeiten 12 Tage
am Stück teilweise weil das Personal
fehlt die Arbeitsverdichtung wird immer
größer 3 Millionen länderbedienstete
fordern wie eher mehr Geld
10,5% Lehrerinnen Polizisten Förster mit
einem Protestmarsch machen sie Druck in
Berlin dort stellen die
Verhandlungsführer der Länder gleich zum
auftagt klar die öffentlichen Kassen
sind leer viel Spielraum gebe es nicht
wir haben zusammengerechnet kommen auf
20,7 Milliarden Euro Forderungsvolumen
das ist zu viel das ist zu teuer wir
brauchen eine Verständigung die fair ist
für die Beschäftigten aber auch leistbar
für die Länderhaushalte doch es gibt do
eine rechtliche Dimension derzug Beamte
Achim Hirz denkt über eine Klage nach
weil das Abstandsgebot zum Bürgergeld
oft nicht eingehalten werde das sei
gesetzlich verbrieft mnt auch der
Beamtenbund wir müssen hier deutlich
mehr machen um die unteren
Einkommensgruppen eben auch im Land
noordinwestfahen wieder attraktiver zu
gestalten das sind Berufsgruppen im
Strafvollzug bei der Polizei und anderen
die stehen im Moment gerade im Fokus der
gesellschaftlichen Auseinandersetzung
doch brauchen die Kolleginen und
Kollegen Wertschätzung mehrere tausend
Beamte in NRW klagen bereits wegen
möglicher Verletzung des Abstands Gebots
wir müssen jeden morgen früh aufstehen
oder auch bis spät in den Abend in der
Nacht arbeiten wir haben unsere Kosten
unter Lebenshaltungskosten wir müssen
zum dienstfahren teilweise 50 60 km und
wenn ich für etwas weniger Geld einfach
zu Hause bleiben kann ist das glaube ich
eine Fehlentwicklung in Deutschland
knappe Kassen wütende Beamte
Rechtsstreitigkeiten es wird keine
einfache Tarifrunde und Achim Hirz wird
notfalls vor Gericht ziehen um seine
Forderungen
durchzusetzen und die Arbeitgeber
bleiben dabei so richtig viel zu
verteilen haben bundländer und Kommunen
nicht das zeigt auch die aktuelle
Steuerschätzung und damit beginnen die
Nachrichten mit Kundel Gusen der Bund
wird im kommenden Jahr zwar etwas mehr
Steuern einnehmen als erwartet aber
Finanzminister Lindner sieht dadurch
keine neuen Verteilungsspielräume wie er
sagte die Steuerschätzer rechnen für
2024 mit Einnahmen von insgesamt gut
964 Milliarden Euro das sind 1,9
Milliarden Euro mehr als in der
Frühjahrsprognose erwartet und diese
mehereinnahmen sein nur auf
Sondereffekte zurückzuführen Valerie
hallle an der Börse was heißt das für
die weitere Entwicklung der
Steuereinnahmen ja also da sieht es zwar
auf der Einnahmeseite etwas besser aus
für Lindner ändert sich an der
angespannten Haushaltslage aber trotzdem
nichts was auch daran liegt dass
Deutschland langsamer aus der Krise
kommt als gedacht grund sind die hohen
Energiepreise die stark gestiegenen
Zinsen und eine insgesamt schwache
Weltwirtschaft für die Zeit bis
2027 sagen die Schätze eine leichte
Erholung voraus und erwarten für den
gesamten schätzraum mehrinnahmen von
insgesamt über 23 Milliarden Euro von
den hohen Zuwachsraten vergangener Jahre
ist das jedoch weit entfernt tatsächlich
könnte die schwache Konjunktur der
Bundesregierung bei den finalen
Haushaltsberatungen in die Karten
spielen Grund ist Seer Regelung der
Schuld Bremse die dem Bund abhängig von
der konjunkturellen Lage geringe Kredite
erlaubt und noch eine Nachfrage zur EZB
Entscheidung die Zinsen unverändert zu
belassen wie haben da die Märkte
reagiert mit Erleichterung haben sie
reagiert wenn auch die Entscheidung
keine Überraschung war die Argumente
Sprachen ziemlich klar für eine
Zinspause allen voran die Konjunktur im
Euroraum die EZB geht davon aus dass die
Wirtschaft vermutlich bis Ende des
Jahres schwach bleibt aus außerdem ist
die Inflation zuletzt gesunken die
Banken vergeben weniger Kredite und der
Immobilienmarkt steht praktisch still
einer baldigen Zinssenkung aber erteilt
IZB Präsidentin lagard eine deutliche
Absage eine Debatte darüber sei völlig
verfrüht vielen Dank an Valerie Haller
in
Frankfurt Thema an der Börse war auch
Siemens Energy die Aktie verlor gut 35%
Hintergrund der Münchner Hersteller von
Kraftwerkstechnik und
Windturbinen benötigt offenbar
staatliche Hilfe es geht um
Kreditbürgschaften von bis zu 15
Milliarden Euro wegen massiver Verluste
bei einer spanischen
windkrafttochtergesellschaft zum
internationalen Fußball in der
europaague hat der SC Freiburg beim
serbischen batka topola 3:1 auswärts
gewonnen einen Spielbericht zu Bayern
Leverkusen gegen Karabach akdam aus
Aserbaidschan gibt es später in unserem
heute journal Update Asterix Fans feiern
die neue Ausgabe der legendären
comikreihe die weiße Iris ist jetzt zu
haben und auf der Höhe der Zeit positiv
denken Stadt prügeln die Spinnen die
Römer das wäre nichts neues das
gallische Dorf hat diesmal einen Coach
Fitness statt Kampf Sushi statt
Wildschwein aber ein von unbeugsamen
gallern bevölkertes Dorf hört nicht auf
Widerstand zu leisten schließlich müssen
sich Asterix und Obelix ja treu
bleiben in der Moskauer Redaktion der
nover gazietta stand ein Schreibtisch
auf dem sich Bücher und Papiere türmten
unaufgeräumt und
unangetastet der Schreibtisch von Anna
politkowskayer die wohl berühmteste
russische Journalistin ihr portraät hing
zusammen mit denen von vier anderen
ermordeten Kollegen im Eingangsflur der
Redaktion inzwischen gibt es das Büro
nicht mehr die novaa gazietta musste ihr
Erscheinen eine Woche nach dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
einstellen eine freie Berichterstattung
ist durch Putins Mediengesetze unmöglich
geworden viele Journalisten sind
gezwungen ins Ausland zu gehen und
versuchen z.B von Berlin aus
weiterzuarbeiten christat lepple hat
zwei von ihnen getroffen die eine kam
wegen politkowskayer zur nover Gazetta
die andere ist ihre Tochter
7 oktober 2006 Putins Geburtstag vor
ihrer Wohnung in Moskau wird die
Journalistin Anna Politkowskaja getötet
fünf Schüsse weil sie unbequeme
Wahrheiten über Russland schrieb Tochter
Vera war schwanger als sie ihre Mutter
verlor seit dem ukrainekrieg libt die
43jährige im Exil liebt sie trotzdem
ihre
Heimat natürlich ohne Zweifel liebe ich
mein Land aber ich untersche zwischen
Land und
macht meine Mutter hätte es Krieg
genannt so heißt ihr Buch Tochter Vera
erzählt ungeschminkt von ihrer Familie
ihrem Land und Putins Feldzug gegen die
Ukraine siegeskult sei die neue
Krankheit Russland schreibt sie Schüler
werden in Militäruniform gesteckt
Mädchen possieren fröhlich mit Waffen
selbst an Ballettschulen militärischer
Drill wer nicht mitmacht
t an Vera und ihre Tochter erhielten
mordrungen sie
[Musik]
gingen in der russischen Mentalität ist
es sehr oft anzutreffen und russische
Menschen sehen das auch so wenn jemand
für längere Zeit ins Ausland geht wird
das als landesfrat
angesehen während Putin Siegesfeiern
zelebriert kratzt die Journalistin
Jelena kchenko mit jeder Zeile am
geschönten
Propagandabild in ihren
Alltagsgeschichten berichtet die 36
wie es wirklich ist in Russland zu leben
und doch hängt sie an ihrem Land ja ich
liebe mein Land ich habe darüber ein
ganzes Buch
geschrieben in ihrem reportageband das
Land das ich liebe berichtet sie von
Dörfern am Ende der Welt im Laden gibt
es nur noch fußel ausgestreckten
Glasreiniger notiert sie und für
Babuschka Tonja muss ein brotleib fün
Tage reichen Jelena hat bereits einen
Anschlag überlebt kurz nach Kriegsbeginn
schloss ihre Zeitung die
auch die junge Reporterin musste
flien das was mit Russland gerade
passiert ist eine ungeheuerliche
Katastrophe vor allem weil das ganze
nicht nur in Russland geschieht sondern
weil Russland seinem Nachbarn Ukraine
den Tod
bringt zwei mutige Frauen zwei vonusen
die ihr Land verlassen mussten ist für
sie eine wel ohne Putin
denkbar vorstellen dass Putin aus
welchem Grund auch immer nicht mehr an
der Spitze von Russland steht wird nicht
alles sofort besser werden nicht in
einem Monat ich befürchte auch nicht in
einem Jahr aber in der
Langzeitperspektive natürlich
schon Bücher die aufrüteln von Frauen
die sich nicht einschüchtern lassen der
Preis der Verlust ihres Landes das sich
mit seinem Krieg selbst
ruiniert zwei starke Frau und wir
empfehlen Ihnen jetzt eine dritte
nämlich Maybritt ilner mit dem Thema
Krieg in narost Gefahr für die Welt
Gäste sind der ehemalige Bundespräsident
Joachim gaug und unser Kollege Christian
Sivas und um 0:30 Uhr also wird sich
Laura barnik mit unserem heute journal
Update melden und morgen erwarten Sie
hier gundola Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen Abend tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend das hier ist der Jet das
stark windband in etwa 10 km Höhe es ist
sowas wie die lightplanke für Tiefs
bedeutet einfach dass dieser Jet bei uns
in Mitteleuropa häufig von West nach Ost
verläuft und so ist es ja schon seit
Tagen so dass wir es mit einem stabilen
tief über dem Atlantik zu tun haben und
da schwimmen diese tiefsen dieser
westlichen Strömung einfach mit morgen
kommt ein Tief das bringt nicht nur
Regen mit sondern in den Alpen auch
Schnee und vorerst bleiben wir von den
milderen Temperaturen noch ein bisschen
abgeschnitten aber das wird sich zum
Wochenende ändern dann sind durchaus an
die 20° möglich heute Nacht fällt
erstmal Regen in der Südhälfte im
Nordosten gibt's noch einige
Regenschauer die Temperaturen sinken auf
11° am oberrehein und bis 6° in der mag
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 10° an der Ostsee und auch im
vogland und maximal 17° am oberrehein
und morgen regnet es ja erstmal kräftig
dann zieht der Regen ostwärts ab und am
Alp Rand kann es ganz freundlich werden
hinter dem Regen lockern die Wolken auch
mal auf dann gibt's hier westlich des
Rheins oder am oberrehein aber auch mal
kräftige Schauer vielleicht sogar mal
ein Gewitter am Samstag wird sich an
diesem Wetter noch wenig ändern am
Sonntag wird es dann hier im Nordwesten
stürmisch und dann kann es mit föen
unter Stützung in Bayern für 20° am
Sonntag reichen die neue Woche startet
ähnlich guten Abend